going with my habit of overly simplified
economy let's imagine economy that has
only two actors in it so it has mr
farmer right over here do my best to
draw the farmer maybe he has a mustache
of some kind so it has mr farmer right
over here he's got a hat on so it has mr
farmer so that is the farmer in this
economy and then let's say we also have
a builder so
this economy they're producing two
things they're producing food and this
builder can help maintain stuff so maybe
he has a lot more maybe this is the
builder right over here
so this is mr
this is mr builder
and let's say for the sake of what we're
going to do here let's say that for this
economy it's kind of a constant if
either of these fellows gets an extra
dollar to spend he's going to spend 60
of it and so what i'm going to do is
introduce a formal word that really is
just another way of saying that in this
economy the marginal propensity to
consume marginal
propensity
to
consume
is when i'll put that in parentheses
it's often referred to as mpc that is
equal to
you could either say 60
or it's equal to 0.6
and all this is saying is that if
someone in this economy somehow finds
another dollar in their pocket they're
going to spend 0.6 of that or they're
going to spend 60 of that so if you give
the builder if a builder all of a sudden
gets an extra dollar he's going to spend
another 60 cents on other things and the
only person to really spend it with is
the farmer if the farmer gets another
dollar he's going to spend 60 of that or
60 cents with the builder now given this
assumption let's think about what would
happen in this economy
if all of a sudden one of them decided
to increase their spending a little bit
so we'll assume that they're they were
all living happily the economy was kind
of at a steady state and let's say the
farmer discovers a a sock in a drawer
that he didn't realize was there and
it's got a little bit of their agreed
upon currency maybe the agreed upon
currency in this island is the dollar
they've maybe got a stash when they when
they're shipwrecked on this or whatever
so the agreed upon currency is actually
the dollar and the farmer discovers that
he's got that he wants to he discovers a
big pile of dollars in his in his in his
in his sock and he says well i'm gonna
spend a thousand dollars on i need to do
some repairs to my buildings
so let's say so we have this and we have
this kind of increase in spending that's
going on so the farmer says hey i'm
going to spend
i'm going to spend
1 000 and i'm going to give it to the
builder
now the builder says well you know gee
i've i've i've just gotten a thousand
dollars i have a marginal propensity to
consume of 60 or 0.6 i'm going to spend
60 of that so he's going to spend so
he's going to spend and the only person
he can spend it with is the farmer he's
going to spend 60 percent
times 1 000
which is equal to 600
well now the farmer says well i just i
got above and beyond the thousand that i
just spent somehow you know the economy
seems to be picking up the builder just
spent six hundred dollars more on me
than he would have otherwise done he
bought that much more food
i have six hundred dollars more i have a
marginal propensity to consume of zero
point six or sixty percent so i will
spend sixty percent of that six hundred
dollars that i just got and so it will
be it will be sixty percent of this
thing so it will be sixty i'll write it
as a decimal it'll be zero point six
times this thing which is
which is
zero point six times one thousand or you
could say it is sixty percent of the six
hundred dollars which is going to be
equal to three hundred and sixty dollars
well now the builder says well you know
i got that initial thousand dollars i
spent 600 that but now i got another 360
and i have a marginal propensity to
consume of 0.6 so i'm going to spend 60
of that so above and beyond this
spending he also spends 60 of this right
over here and percent of this is 0.6
times this whole thing so he's going to
spend
0.6
times this thing and i'll write it in
green times 0.6 times 0.6 times
one thousand dollars
now this number right over here i don't
know what this is is sixty percent of
three hundred and sixty dollars i don't
know i can get a calculator out to
figure out what that is exactly so let's
say that
let's say that i have so 0.6
we could actually say 0.6 to the third
power
.6 or let's just let's just write that
or 0.6 to the third
and then i'm going to multiply that
times 1000
gives us 216
so this guy so this right over here
gives us 216 this guy says hey i got
another 216 dollars i'm going to spend
60 percent of that and i think you see
where this is going
and 60 of that is going to be 0.6 times
this whole quantity so it's going to be
i'll write it here it's going to be 0.6
times this thing which was already 0.6
times 0.6 times 0.6 so you're going to
have 0.6 times 0.6 to the third power
that's going to be 0.6 to the fourth
power times 1000 times 1000 which is
whatever 60 percent of 216 is and i'll
just calculate it so that's so times 0.6
gives us 130
is going to get
129.6 dollars now this guy the builder
says oh i got another 129.6 i'm going to
spend 60 of that and it goes on and on
and on so given this let's think about
how much from that incremental that
incremental increase of spending of a
thousand dollars how much total new
production and spending happened in this
economy so the way to think about that
so the total
total
total and we could view it either way
remember you can view kind of the gdp
you could do that as the aggregate
output you could view that as the
aggregate income aggregate expenditure
these are all views because really the
economy is a very circular thing one
person's expenditure turns into another
person's income
but we could say total output here total
output measured in our agreed upon
currency which is let's say dollars this
is now going to be it was this original
thousand that the farmer spent for the
builder so it's going to be that
original thousand
plus this first right over here this
point six times a thousand that the
builder spent at six hundred dollars so
that's zero point six
times
one thousand
plus then we had this time the farmer
said i'm gonna spend sixty percent of
that so that was point six squared times
a thousand
plus 0.6
squared times
1 000. and then this guy said oh i'm
going to spend 60 percent of that now
that i got that .6 squared times a
thousand so that he's going to take 60
percent of that and spend it and that
gave us that 0.6 to the third power
times a thousand plus 0.6 to the third
power times
1000 and then we and then the last one
we we did would keep going on and on
forever theoretically is you're going to
have the 0.6
is you're going to have plus 0.6 to the
fourth power times
1000 and that this would keep going on
and on forever we could then would be
plus 0.6 to the fifth power times 1000
plus 0.6 to the sixth power keep going
on and on forever and the one way and
then one of the fascinating things about
mathematics and maybe the next video
i'll reprove this i've proven this in
multiple playlists is that you can
actually sum up because this value right
over here is less than one this actually
ends up being a finite sum you can
actually take this infinite sum and get
a finite number so just to simplify this
the total output from that that's kind
of sparked by that original thousand
dollars we can factor out the thousand
i'll do this in a new color so we can
factor out the thousand and we are left
with well if you factor out a thousand
there you get one plus
zero point six plus zero point six
squared plus
zero point six the third power plus
0.6 to the fourth power and it goes on
and on and on and in the next video
maybe i'll prove it just for fun but
this right over here it's an infinite
sum of a geometric series and this will
actually simplify to
this right here simplifies to i'll do it
in the same green color as 1 over 1
minus
0.6 so whatever this number is right
over here it'll be 1 minus 1 over that
and so in this case this would be equal
to
this would be equal to 1 over
1 over
0.4 and 0.4 is two-fifths so this is
equal to one over two-fifths which is
equal to
five-halves so your total output your
total output is going to be equal to
is going to be equal to one thousand
times
times five halves or this is the same
thing as equal to one thousand
times two and a half which is equal to
twenty five hundred so there's two
interesting ideas that are going here is
one is when people get a little bit more
income they're going to spend some of it
and that's where the marginal propensity
to consume is we're assuming it's linear
that no matter how much you give them
they're just going to spend 60 percent
of that and then given that and that
that 60 percent it keeps getting
multiplied and going through the economy
you essentially have this multiplier
fact that that thousand got spent some
fraction of that gets spent then some
fraction of that gets spent and so what
we ended up doing is that thousand that
first thousand dollars got multiplied by
2.5 got 2.5 and this 2.5 was completely
a function of what the marginal
propensity to consume was so we have
this relationship here is that whatever
the marginal propensity to consume is
that drives the multiplier that drives
the multiplier and all the multiplier is
saying is if you spend an extra dollar
in this economy given people's marginal
propensity to consume how much will that
increase total output